you
we all started as one team we all wanted
to be superheroes for the same reason
you're a traitor tweek and now you're
with a group of super traitors this was
started by you we are the ones who
walked out the stuffy franchise
mysterion why would the freedom Pal tell
us we send a spy someone in our group
who pretends to want to switch sides and
join freedom pack
somebody who they don't know very well
all that there is nothing more freedom
[ __ ] [ __ ] at all you've got problems
nuclear whatever you did last night got
a lot of people's attention bad people
if you need information just know you
can rely on call town who does spot is
that so I guess now any [ __ ] [ __ ]
thinks they can be a superhero
we're gonna rip you apart you really
hate me Union
[Music]
hello tool shed tool shed is a cactus
here class visionary architect and a
blood sucking trader
Eric your must listen to me dad my head
tinny your franchise is going nowhere
ladies the truth Eric you guys are kind
of Duty fast he just caught a snooze
bags in my man he did snap ha the
fractured but home is available October
17th get the stick of truth free with
purchase pre-order now for TOWIE bonus
content don't forget to bring it now
[Music]